in a fast-moving world keeping in touch
is essential but it shouldn't cost an
arm and a leg and it should be possible
wherever you are that's why Parliament
is bringing telecoms rules up to date
any piece want to put an end to
expensive calls within the EU from May
2019 phone calls should be captured 19
cents and texts are just six cents in
many country will be a union this is
going to no substantive decreasing of
the course which is shown as something
that I'm sure the European consumers
they will work on it would be easier for
customers to monitor their phone use and
keep an eye on their bills remember
you're not married to your phone
provider so leaving it when you find a
better deal should be easier you could
even receive compensation if they are
too slow to let you go your personal
information is precious this is why
Parliament wants to promote secure
end-to-end encryption web-based services
like Skype and whatsapp will also be
covered by the same rules and because of
no one likes hanging around for slow
internet connections MEP SWAT super high
speed 5g to start hitting major European
cities in 2020
[Music]